some pretty epic teams are going to be
coming to the MCU pretty soon lately we
have been talking about Marvel studios's
new plan for the MCU with Jonathan major
being found guilty and being fired from
Marvel Studios Kang the Conqueror is
going to be taking a back seat for a
pretty long time in fact we probably
won't see him again until Avengers
Secret Wars but in the meantime Marvel
Studios does have a plan to bring in
some new teams and they're also going to
be diving into a newer side of the MCU
that fans have been really liking so far
yes the X-Men are coming and yes an
X-Men movie could be coming and an
official X-Men team could be formed a
lot sooner than we think that's super
exciting to think about and if you want
to learn more about that you can check
out the video we did yesterday but in
this video we are going to be talking
about the darker side of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and we are going to
be talking about the team the midnight
Suns thanks to some new reports it looks
like we might have our official lineup
for the new midnight Suns team that is
going going to be coming in the
Multiverse Saga so before Phase 6 ends
which is great news because I would love
to see characters like blade and
moonight and other dark characters be a
part of Avengers Secret Wars as well
plus not to mention for a very long time
we didn't exactly know when the Scarlet
Witch would return however it looks like
she could be returning for the midnight
Suns team so let's break down the
reported lineup for the midnight Suns
team coming in the Multiverse Saga but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news we're also giving away a
PS5 and Xbox series X and more we'll
talk about that at the end of the video
but only a handful of days left in this
month's giveaway now in the past handful
of videos we have talked about Alex
Perez over at the cosmic circus he did a
huge article basically talking about the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
talking about the different components
of it as always we will link that down
below please be sure to check out that
article and support them but of course
in today's video we are specifically
going to be talking about the rise of
the midnight suns in the art article
when talking about the future of the MCU
Alex Perez specifically mentioned the
rise of the Midnight Sun stating one
corner of the MCU that Marvel is Keen on
exploring for these next few phases is
the supernatural corner of their
Universe projects like moonnight
werewolf by night and W division have
already introduced some critical
components for this corner of the MCU
and that's insanely true like incredibly
true W division is typically viewed as
the best Disney plus project so far by a
lot of different fans I loved it a lot
of fans truly loved it and it was weird
and different and dark and it was great
same thing with moonight moonnight was
very refreshing because it was very
different and it did have those
Supernatural darker tones and werewolf
by night took a lot of people including
myself by surprised with how good it
actually was all of these projects were
received very very well so it makes
sense that Marvel Studios would want to
dive deeper into this category
especially since they have already
announced blade and based off of what
we've heard so far about blade yes it
got off to a really rough start and yes
the script has been Rewritten like four
times but based off what we've heard now
Mersa Ali does like the script now and
things seem to be going a lot better now
in the article Alex Perez goes on to
list a handful of projects that are
going to continue to explore the
supernatural darker side of the MCU and
these projects include blade of course
Iron Heart Marvel Zombies moonnight
season 2 the continuation of werewolf by
night and other unannounced projects as
well now blade is a given obviously but
iron heart we know that the hood is
going to be a part of it and based off
of some reports Sasha barican is playing
Maisto and this show is going to involve
some very dark magic which is why it is
a Supernatural Project and a darker
project as well if they're going to
introduce a character who's basically
the devil a demon then Marvel Zombies
obviously is going to have that darker
tone to it and moonnight season 2 this
has been talked about for a bit now
Daniel rpk reported this about a month
or two ago that Marvel Studios is
currently talking about right now
moonnight season 2 and Miss Marvel
season 2 and werewolf by night well it
looks like some of those characters from
that project are going to be a part of
the midnight Suns team Alex perz stated
in the article this Arc aims to unite
the heroes of this Supernatural Corner
against a significant threat to humanity
giving rise to the midnight Suns some
sources have mentioned that Lilith or
Mesto villains have been considered the
big bag of this Ark One Source has
mentioned that the potential lineup for
the midnight Suns features the current
sorcerer Supreme Wong as the leader of
the team alongside Mersa Ali's blade but
since this article has come out Alex
Perez has hinted even more at who the
characters on this team are going to be
and let's start off with the member that
everybody has been wondering about and
that is the Scarlet Witch make no
mistake the Scarlet Witch Is Not Dead
Wanda is still alive in the MCU and she
will be returning Agatha the darkhold
diary may not show us Wanda although
they will severely hint at her in the
show and be very connected to her
however the ending is supposed to be the
witches Road special presentation which
is supposed to be heavily connected to
the Scarlet Witch as well and Kevin fagy
the president of Marvel Studios
basically confirmed a long time ago that
Wanda is not dead he said that when the
mountain fell on her you notice a little
red light that's all I'll say about that
that's what he said basically stating
she's not dead and of course she's not
she is the most powerful character in
the MCU right now that has been
introduced to us some rocks falling on
her wouldn't kill her and if the rumors
are true about misto and he is going to
be a pretty big villain a part of the
Multiverse Saga imposing a huge threat
on the universe and possibly the
Multiverse then Wanda is going to need
to be in this fight plus not to mention
they could change it up a bit from the
comics and say that Mesto could be
responsible for the dark hold which of
course is directly connected to Wanda so
she'll definitely want to be involved
now like Alex Perez said Wong is going
to be in the group and he is probably
going to be the leader he is the
sorcerer Supreme this makes sense in
fact he's probably going to be the Nick
Fury of the midnight Suns team he is
probably the one who gathers everybody
together then of course we have blade
this is a no-brainer they are basically
putting him in there so he could be a
part of the midnight Suns of course
he'll have his own movie but he's always
been a pretty prominent character in The
Midnight Suns team then of course like
we mentioned before moonnight as we know
konu is not gone poor old Steven Grant
just can't get a break but that's good
for us because he's going to return to
be a part of the midnight Suns team then
the next three members are actually
coming from werewolf by night and that
is Elsa Bloodstone Jack Russell and man
thing and this makes a ton of sense
since werewolf by night really set up a
huge part of the supernatural side of
the MCU so it's looking like our roster
right now for the midnight Suns team is
man thing Elsa Bloodstone werewolf By
Night Wong blade moonnight and the
Scarlet Witch which honestly sounds
really really awesome and for those
wondering about some other characters
who have been a part of the midnight
suns in the comics like Doctor Strange
Deadpool and even some characters who
have been a part of the game this is
just the first team established in the
MCU it doesn't mean that other
characters won't join it doesn't mean
some characters won't leave so don't
think of this as the final and only
midnight Suns team that we'll see in the
MCU I'm expecting there to be many
iterations of this team throughout the
MCU as we continue on even past Avengers
Secret Wars because of course after
Secret Wars then we could get some X-Men
on the team like Wolverine so all in all
I'm super excited for the supernatural
side of the MCU and this lineup right
here actually gets me very excited as
well I'm excited to see the Scarlet
Witch return and I love thinking about
her interacting with moonight and Wong
once again because of everything she did
in Multiverse of Madness however if Wong
is the one who is gathering all these
people together he must know that he
needs Wanda which if they are dealing
with a Lilith or Mesto he definitely
does need her which is probably why
she's on the team so drop your thoughts
about this lineup in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
the MCU and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month and happy holidays
to everybody I hope everybody has a
great and safe time this holiday season
and a great end of 2023 wolof wolof